Do you like my jacket? We need AI
everywhere. But it's not because we
don't love GeForce.
We don't love GeForce. Let this sink in.
I promise I'll talk about AI. AI. Nvidia
is not a technology company anymore. Get
used to it.
>> Has Jensen hired any Dark Brotherhood
assassins yet?
>> Dark Brotherhood.
You make me happy.
[Music]
>> Hey,
do you like my jacket?
>> It's only possible with the power of AI.
Only $250 and you can be 50 times
better.
You don't believe me? Let me show you.
[Music]
Oh, it microenter.
How did that get here, though? I guess I
drove at at one point. I don't I don't
know when I did that, but
I I got to go to microenter anyways. So,
let's just uh I'll just go in, I guess.
[Music]
Hey,
you going shopping?
>> I don't want to go shopping. Yeah, I'm
going to go look at some CPUs right now.
I guess I can get away from them.
>> Yeah. You don't need to look at those.
>> I don't.
>> Guess what?
>> Just like this.
>> I got you a gift.
>> See this
>> here? Remember I said it was affordable?
>> Yeah.
>> You have it free charge.
5500. You'll have to get DDR4. This is
DDR5.
>> All right, I'm getting out of here.
>> No more running.
>> Come on. Let's get you home. I went
through
>> I wasn't going to get rid of it.
>> Shut up. Shut up.
>> I wasn't going to
>> shut.
>> I went through all the effort to get you
here so you can experience greatness
with Nvidia's black wall architecture.
You like my jacket?
Affordable frame gen. I mean, I'm sure
you could still get the 5090 and
everything.
>> The more you buy, the more you save.
>> A couple of these, you won't need a
5090, now would you?
>> It's 50 times faster.
>> Exactly. 50 times faster. 50 more
frames, 50 more series.
Don't you love that?
Come on, say you love it.
>> Yeah. Do I have to unbox it?
>> Hell yeah, you do. It's your card. And
I'm just going to make sure you know
your car is right here. You can go home
as soon as you're done. Don't you want
that? You want to go home, don't you?
Okay.
I want those fake frames.
[Applause]
It's very nice. Jensen, why is it over
there?
Very high quality.
You can hear the innovation in that. Got
got that side.
All right.
Can I go home now?
Do I have to use it?
Okay.
[Music]
um
doesn't reach. It's on the wrong side.
It's really uh
high quality and a lot of weight to this
thing.
All right.
[Music]
Look at it. It's beautiful.
Please don't harm me. Please don't harm
me. It's beautiful.
We got a We got a Valve hardware survey
and
>> feed of misinformation. Yes. Everybody
uses the 50/50. What's your take on the
card? I know you haven't seen it yet.
So, like, how do you feel about it right
now?
>> Uh, it spins.
>> It's 50 times faster, right? We could do
4K.
>> Yeah, 4K.
>> That's pretty good.
>> Yeah, we got like 24. Oh, it's cinematic
though.
>> I mean, you're not supposed to play any
movie game really above 30 frames a
second. I will say like it's a little
choppy for me. I think if we use some
frame gen then we'll be we'll be
chilling.
>> This is what times four is for.
>> Oh man. Oh, it's only times two.
>> Not bad.
>> We get even more frames.
>> Check out this
>> 60. Hey, you guys are saying skip this
card. It's playing at 4K 60.
>> Yep.
>> On what? Hi.
>> Mhm.
>> This is gaming. Sheesh. Oh yeah. Look at
this.
>> He just his mouse is dying. That's all.
Feel it.
>> It's like the Switch, too.
>> You feel drunk when you're playing it.
Uh, we just use more DLSS.
>> Yeah. I mean, DLSS is 4K.
>> Mhm. Quality.
>> Yeah. Quality.
>> We lend you quality. Oo, look how
buttery smooth.
>> It still feels drunk. Look at that text.
>> Something's a little little wrong here.
>> Oh, he just didn't he doesn't have the
right drivers, guys.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You know what you should do?
>> This is a 1080p card, right?
>> Don't worry, it's going.
>> There it is. Yeah, had to ado 100 at 4K.
>> Yeah, we've only got like 80
milliseconds of latency.
>> I imagine this can run 1080p at a
perfect 480 Hz. Not hertz, FPS.
>> Well, shoot. I think we got to try it.
>> This is how you're really supposed to
use this card. 164 this frame gen on.
>> Hey, we're frame generating from 43.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay. Now, let's see. Let's turn
off frame gen. We get a solid like 70 f
FPS. That's That's pretty That's pretty
good, guys. Yeah, like it's RTX card. It
should be able to do rate tracing,
right? I like reflections. You like
reflections?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, they look pretty cool.
>> I mean, consoles don't run more than 30,
so
>> Yeah, it's true. Oh, we got a solid
>> 40.
I mean, it can do that. It should be
able to do more, right?
>> Yeah. Patch race. And look at the
wattage. I'm just saying.
>> Yeah, we're doing all of this at like 90
watts.
If it makes up its mind.
>> I mean, if we upscale this, it would be
a 30. Uh, we going to we can uh run it
from 540p.
I think that should work. We're getting
a solid 12 to 13. Oh, is it kicking in?
>> Oh, yeah. Now we're getting 28. Oh. Oh,
they hit the big three. 3 0.
>> Oh, banana. Banana.
>> I think we need to go a little bit
lower.
>> Yeah, let's try it.
>> 360p.
Uh uh. Oh.
A This is an AI image at this
point.
What the hell is happening?
This looks so weird.
>> It's like a acid trip.
>> Wow.
>> These graphics are crazy. This is just a
perspective of a crackhead screaming on
the A train in New York.
>> Yeah, I think we got we got to pedal
some frames.
>> Yeah.
>> Back into it.
>> Amazing. This looks
>> all you guys have to do is just have 50
screws. You won't have to worry about
not running anything ever again.
>> There's only a little bit of problems
when I swing my weapon.
>> Do you see the trails around it?
>> It's okay, though.
>> I actually don't care about your
feelings.
>> Yep. And right now, I feel like this is
one of the best graphics cards of the
year.
>> There's no arguing this. It looks great,
runs great, runs path tracing on a $250
graphics card. Honestly, I think Nvidia
is getting a little bit too generous.
>> Yeah, I'm not going to lie, they did up
the VRAM a little bit. They should go
back to six.
>> Yeah. Over hated.
>> Over hated, underrated, and should be
mandated on people's computers.
>> There's no flaws in the image
whatsoever. It's the Flash. He's in the
speed voice. Man, I'm really glad that
kind stranger was able to get me this
legendary graphics card from Nvidia. The
RTX 5050. I'm honestly kind of sad that
Nvidia hasn't tried to make this more
available and more well-known. The 5050
has been a weird situation for basically
everyone. And I think there's some
specific reasons for that. It started
off Oops, you can't see me. But it
started off on Nvidia's website and now
it looks a little bit different, but I
have a screenshot of what it used to
look like back uh when it was first
announced. The 50/50 was said to be $250
and it was going to come out in the
second half of July. There wasn't even
an official release date. It just was
coming out in this range in July, which
wasn't necessarily not true, but there
was reports basically that the 50/50
kind of existed. it it was out there but
then it wasn't being sold at the time in
this weird limbo state where this
product is half launched half not
launched and we're at MicroEnter. Yes,
we did have to buy the graphics card. It
didn't just magically appear. This is
what it looks like on MicroEnter's
website now. You have to buy stuff in
person there. It's a brick andmortar
store. Now, when we were going to get it
before, imagine their website more so
looked like this. It was literally just
two versions of the 50/50 available.
This one had like two units available
and then this had like three. So
obviously this one hasn't really sold
that well to be honest. So there wasn't
that much available. It was interesting
as the employees didn't even know that
the 50/50 was available at all.
>> I don't know why this exists.
>> Jonathan, huh?
>> Do they exist?
>> They exist. Yeah,
>> they exist.
>> Yeah, we we we want one.
>> I will grab one, I guess. I don't know
where
>> it's absolute cinema. We want the
masterpiece. and they had to go dig
through the back and actually took them
quite a while to even find where the
hell the 50-50s were. There was like
five of them there and that seems to be
like an intentional thing from Nvidia
that they kind of wanted to hide this
graphics card. I mean, not that there's
anything wrong with it. It's a great
graphics card. I swear. I swear. But
it's been quite hidden. You check out
like reviews that have come out about
the RTX 5050. There really isn't that
many out there. I mean, there is this
one from Hardware Unbox. There's one
here from Tech Notice. And then there's
one here from like Random Gaming HD.
There's some out there available from
like Daniel Owen and Dalwood or David. I
I don't know how the hell you pronounce
it. They're kind of out there, but you
see some of the bigger channels like
Gamers Nexus and Linus Tech Tips and
stuff. There isn't that many of those
type of reviews out like really digging
into the product. It's because Nvidia
has done a successful strategy of kind
of letting this GPU go under the radar.
So, now we have the third 8 GB Blackwell
GPU, the RTX50.
And for this one, there was no review
samples at all. So, not having the
driver was a non-issue for this one. And
in fact, we couldn't even purchase it
until several days after it was meant to
appear on shelves. They didn't send them
out to reviewers at all, which isn't a
necessary thing, by the way, but it does
seem suspicious when they want to hide
the product. And if you still go to
Nvidia's press website, they're still
talking about the 5060 Ti on there.
Like, they're acting like a 5060 never
came out. They're acting like a 5050
never came out because they didn't send
them to reviewers. They don't want them
to be out there. That gets me thinking a
little bit is like, hey, why does Nvidia
not want them to be shown? The budget
graphics card, $250. It must be a great
deal. I don't see anything wrong with
that. And when you see their website of
the announcement of the RTX 5050, if you
scroll down just a little bit, 50 times
the performance of the RTX or GTX 1050,
I don't even know exactly what they're
qualifying this as. The thing about it
is it's kind of a a stretch because
they're including things like DLSS frame
generation and then DLSS um super
resolution on the 50/50. We all know
that the frame generation has a little
bit of problems, especially on these
lower-end graphics cards that don't have
enough performance to get the base frame
rate you're actually playing at in the
game before it gets generated. They're
not fast enough to get that number high
enough for responsive and less artifacty
experience. The 50/50 struggles there,
at least it seems like. I'm going to do
some more in-depth testing for this.
Yeah, they do market it with 50 times
performance on there. that it's going to
struggle to do those numbers. And frame
generation, as I've proven, is not the
same thing as real performance, even
though it can still be a useful
technology. So, that's like one of the
reasons why it seems like they're
wanting to hide this. That's why I had
to go out of my way to obtain this RTX
5050. But also, I think Nvidia is a
little bit scared of the competition
around this price point because this
card is going for $250, which is, you
know, their cheapest graphics card
available. But also, AMD is starting to
compete around this price point. The
9060 XT 8 GBTE has generally been going
for like $270 $275.
And something I want to point out too is
when we were at MicroEnter, this 8 GB
960 XT, all the 16 GB versions of this
card because VRAM is very valuable
nowadays. 8 GB is going to struggle. The
8 GB ones were sitting on shelves like
crazy. Nobody seems like they're buying
them, but the 161 gig ones were all out
of stock. And I'm pretty damn sure that
they're making more of the 16 GB ones.
So that means the 8 gig ones are like
really not selling. But to be honest,
for this price point, and I don't have
this one to actually compare against 20
to $30 more than the 5050, I would be
buying this graphics card every single
time. It is so much faster. FSR4 is
starting to get into more games now.
DLSS is more reliably in games, but FSR4
is definitely getting up there. This
card is probably the best value, which
is funny because the 96 XT 8 GB was
literally the bare minimum AMD could
make and it's somehow still competitive
with Nvidia's cards. But I didn't want
to leave you off on just that little bit
of performance that we were able to test
on the 50/50. I do have some more
numbers. Generally speaking, and I'm
going to look through my numbers right
now, but I mainly just did some 1080p
ones really quick. Can be quite a bit
faster in games like Black Ops 6, like
36% faster. Games like Blackmth Wukong,
21% faster. Expedition 33, we see a
pretty large increase. In Cyberpunk,
another decently large increase there.
Kingdom Come Deliverance 2, pretty large
increase. There's quite a few games
where the 5050 seems to fall behind
quite a bit. And if you were to consider
the price point, I can see why Nvidia
wouldn't really want people to get this
graphics card because it's like 20% more
expensive than the 5060. You get the
same amount of VRAM, but it's usually
more than 20% faster. So, in Nvidia's
own lineup, it's kind of mid. What's
tough about this card is 8 GB of VRAM at
the budget price point. More games are
using more than 8 GB of VRAM. And
honestly, I this isn't even like an
amazing esports GPU if you were to want
to make that argument. Like, it's like
okay, it can play the games. I guess can
buy this card on the shelf on its own if
you really want to. if you really really
are addicted to pain or something. But
Nvidia wants to kind of obscure its
existence of actually buying them
individually. I think they want to put
these in pre-built PCs to be honest. And
that is the same thing with the 5060.
Same thing with the 5060 Ti 8 GB. This
is something on the budget side of the
market that a lot of people just see
Nvidia in a system or even be able to
get a $250 current generation Nvidia GPU
and a lot of people are just going to be
like, "Oh I might get that." And
I'm excited to do more of a full
in-depth review on this. I'm also seeing
in so much my 5060 like testing data
that it has like a really really bad
like stutters compared to even the
50/50. So I'm probably going to retest
the 5060 and then retest the 50 or not
retest it but fully test the 50/50. Let
me know what you think about it.
Hopefully I don't run into the frame
peddler again. I mean that guy was kind
of scary.
Hey, even though he can help me out
sometimes. Also, I feel like I should do
this cuz I never really do. If you
haven't subscribed to the channel, get
them numbers up, baby. That's been it
for me. I'm going to see you guys in the
next video. I'll see you guys. Peace.
[Music]